hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slow-mo
guys don't know about you but I really
like getting new toys love it so this
time I've got a vacuum
chamber never done this before no there
was a really good video by action lab
where he put in some gold leaf and just
eviscerated it with the pressure
Equalization so we've got some very thin
gold this is actually some just foil
really it's not it's not that's not real
gold no but we do have real gold we do
have some real gold yeah
we don't want to mess with it in the
intro because we will destroy it in case
you didn't know what gold was this is
looks like gold okay we're going to use
two cameras we've got our very fast
camera which will be shooting fast and
over here we've got our not so fast
camera but it's on the bolt so it'll be
moving fast look like a right little
scientist I've got to wear these
fetching little gloves that are far too
small for me it's because this gold leaf
is possibly the only thing more fragile
than my ego so I have to really
carefully handle it with like tweezers
and these little gloves Perfect Look at
that and you've constructed this little
gold washing line to
a a little I'm laundering my gold and
while you were doing that I've uh
programmed an orbital robot move on the
bolt so it goes looking inwards the
whole time the focus should stay the
same so it should just take one second
for the bolt to get from A to B it's
currently at B we'll start it on the
other side
lovely stuff Focus seemed to be decent
the whole way but what I might do is
actually just add a bit of shutter so
I'll open up to 28 on the aperture and
I'll go down to a 0 on the shutter so
same exposure but a slight rearranging
how do we feel we feel good closed
plugged in turning
on there we
go the first part is really quick and
then it really slows down when it gets
towards the end
yeah okay robot fast 3 2 1
go wow like Christmas
morning it's like a snow globe except
like bling it's like a bling Globe yeah
I could really use a polarizing filter
on this lens just looks like an advert
at the moment wa that is rapid it's like
if you left your laundry out in a
tornado
if you left your like Silk bed sheets
out looks on the end of The Crystal
Maze well there's that one bit just
hanging on for dear
life God that was so fast like it only
tears up in the first few seconds it's
basically just like an air cannon
essentially yeah except the chamber
itself is sucking the air in rather than
the pressure from the like still from
the perspective of that nozzle it's just
blasting air in there yeah it's as if
the entire planet's atmosphere was a
pressure chamber for an air cannon it's
like the end of Space
Balls I like that it most of it goes
straight into the ceiling just because
the air is clearly going down and then
yeah going around the bottom all right
should we try one that just flat on the
floor just flat yeah just laid out flat
on the surface yeah all right see if it
if it differs
yep okay got our flat flat leaf
in I'm ready when you are 3 2 1 go
wof it just dis like to the blink of an
eye it just
[Music]
disappeared okay so this is the real
stuff this is the real deal and now this
stuff is next to
Impossible like it's it's you look at it
funny and it just disappears you can eat
it are you going to have Z I mean that
would be yeah I could do our props have
you ever seen the footage of I think it
was people in Japan making this from
just a block of gold
ohc hundreds and hundreds of hours of
hammering on a piece of metal oh look at
that just can't beat a slice of gold you
cannot oh he's done it it's so it's
flowing like a like it's almost like a
liquid don't breathe okay that I'm I'm
shock what did the crisp say to the
egg I actually don't have a punch line
for
that shut
up okay let's see if real gold behaves
differently look at it blowing in the
lack of
wind well it's the wind leaving oh gosh
pretty much stopped dead well I think
there's no air now it's a vacuum okay
let me get get us into
position camera armed 3 2 1
go 3 2 1
go just vanished it just became
completely different just missed oh we
should use this you think so yeah oh
man okay so now we're switching from the
flex 4K to the TMX for some seriously
fast speeds stop talk
K okay we're back to the little washing
line that's the real gold so the should
go really tiny and the TMX is set to
50,000 frames a second is that going to
be enough I think it'll be enough you
reckon well that's 50 times slower than
we've been seeing I mean it turns to
mist so we'll see this is a Mist
Seer sucking
up
3 2 1
[Music]
pop oh you can actually see some air
coming in I thought it just immediately
popped wow look at all the lines going
through it it looks so because it's so
like fluid it looks much bigger than it
is it looks like liquid for a second
there doesn't it and then it just gets
blasted apart you can really see it in
this frame rate it looks like someone
blew a hole in the Luna Lander that's
exactly what it does look like that is
exactly it oh it's like a it's like some
sort of advert where all there's like
out of focus stuff coming towards you
and then there's the InFocus stuff and
then it it actually just smash like it's
it's like hitting the wood at the bottom
and getting
smaller 3 2 1 pop yeah you can see the
loose bits of gold flying off already a
it just starts peeling from the edges oh
it looks like you know in The Terminator
when the nuke goes off and everyone just
sort of like gets Blown Away doesn't it
just the girl just got Sarah conned in
the
[Laughter]
playground who it looks cool that looks
really cool I love the light against the
gold the reflections it's brilliant I
would have thought the the middle would
have been peeled first I thought it
would just cut a hole and gone out from
the middle but it just it's being like
held against the bottom yeah it's like
the edge flapp is what goes first yeah
just it just like washes away like a
liquid looks like a splash
yeah it just goes in all directions
evenly look it just goes anywhere except
where it was yeah and now now you can
see because it's curling around it's
getting smashed back down into where
it's going in a cyclone now I'm just
going to throw in the rest of the gold
on top of some fake gold it's like
goldplated fake gold I'm going to go 80
big ones for the final 3 2 1
pop crap gold didn't go just didn't even
go gosh I think it has to be slightly
crumpled to give it something to yeah
give it a weakness yeah it goes from
this to this in like like 05 seconds no
wonder rapid no wonder that to my eye it
just disappears yeah wonder if it blasts
through all of the gold before or do it
go through layer by layer well I think I
think it whips up the edges which causes
breakage simultaneously of all of it
maybe cuz it's just pummeling the center
down like a pond it looks like a like a
wave in the middle doesn't it like a
lake looks like a gold tidal wave that
is gorgeous that is mental so the area
out of focus at the front you can't
really see but you can see it you can
see on the sides it's the same thing
yeah yeah yeah like you can definitely
see the plane of focus you can pretty
much see exactly where it is oh
occasionally gets like a big Ripple and
there's like an imperfection that causes
a tear through the middle that's
exciting and it just like crowns out I
think that's my favorite bit where it
breaks from the
middle it's crazy how differently they
they behave the fake gold to the real
gold I like that we had different
effects there where it breaks from the
edges and then we have the imperfections
in the Middle where it breaks through
the middle that's cool oh wow that last
so yeah I think as the they cycle around
they're causing damage which causes the
next layer to go and then it's all gone
and this is the fake underneath gold W
fabulous took the words right out of my
mouth hopefully you enjoyed some of
those visuals make sure you subscribe if
you like
slow-mo that's it really nice and simple
that one check this
out oh isn't that nice you can have a
little sample of
that don't like it well I mean it's
metal in it mostly tastes on my finger
to be
honest